Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Rosetta è una missione pazzesca!
E ve lo dico sinceramente.
Raccontare la storia del suo viaggio
è come entrare in un film di fantascienza.
Ma è anche raccontare
di persone vere, in carne ed ossa.
Persone che vengono
da tutte le parti dell’Europa
e si trovano insieme,
e come gruppo lavorano
per creare un sogno incredibile.
Io ho avuto la fortuna di accompagnare
gran parte di questo viaggio
e insieme agli amici
del Centro di Controllo della Missione,
quindi vorrei raccontarvene
qualche episodio.
Il mio contributo personale a Rosetta
inizia nell’anno 2000.
Iniziai a lavorare a Darmstadt
che, per chi non lo sapesse,
è gemellata con Brescia,
quindi mi sembra una coincidenza
piuttosto fortunata.
Il primo giorno di lavoro
mi venne messo in mano
il manuale dei requisiti di sistema
del software per controllare
il satellite Rosetta.
Prima cosa, studiamo cos’è Rosetta.
Rosetta è una missione
che deve studiare una cometa.
Questa cometa è lontanissima.
Ci metterà dieci anni di viaggio.
Sette miliardi di Km.
Poi arriverà alla cometa
e ci farà atterrare sopra un “lander”.
Io cominciavo a guardarmi intorno,
perché ero convinto che fosse uno scherzo.
Ho detto: “Questo è uno scherzo
dei miei colleghi.
Vogliono vedere come reagisco
di fronte a questa storia!”
Non c’era nessuna telecamera.
Non era una candid camera.
Era veramente lo scopo di questa missione.
E la cosa bellissima
è che dopo tanti anni, adesso sono qui
a raccontarvi di qualcosa
che ha prodotto della scienza fantastica.
Quindi siamo partiti
con un’idea che era fantascienza
e ci troviamo con delle cose
veramente bellissime.
Il 2000 è stato importantissimo per me,
perché sono cambiate tante cose.
Ma una cosa su tutte è cambiata,
la definizione di rosetta.
Per tutta la mia vita,
fino a quel momento,
e immagino per qualcuno di voi anche,
rosetta è sempre stata solo questa.
(Risate)
Questa è una rosetta.
(Applausi)
Da quel momento, e immagino
fino alla fine dei miei giorni,
Rosetta invece adesso è tutt’altra cosa.
Rosetta è un satellite bellissimo.
Ha dei pannelli solari
enormi, giganteschi,
64 metri quadrati di superficie.
E un’antenna gigantesca,
che serve per comunicare con la Terra
a queste distanze incredibili,
nello spazio profondo.
E, attaccato su uno dei suoi lati,
c’è Philae, il lander
che appunto scenderà sulla cometa.
Iniziamo il nostro viaggio,
e Rosetta sta nella punta
di questo razzo che vedete.
Questo è un Ariane 5,
il razzo più potente dell’ESA.
I razzi vengono lanciati
da Kourou, nella Guyana Francese,
e in quel momento noi,
nell’ESOC, a Darmstadt,
siamo seduti in console
e siamo perfettamente impotenti,
perché tutto dipende dall’Ariane 5.
Se tutto va bene, il satellite
entra nella sua orbita iniziale
e da li poi comincerà
una sequenza automatica,
aprirà i suoi pannelli solari,
si metterà in contatto con la Terra,
e noi cominciamo a guidare.
Ma in questi momenti
voi immaginate la tensione di persone
che hanno lavorato anni e anni e anni,
e tutto dipende
dal successo di questo momento.
Quindi, la nostra concentrazione
è nello sperare che semplicemente
tutto vada bene,
per darci poi il nostro lavoro.
Questo è l’inizio
di un viaggio incredibile.
Quello che vi voglio mostrare
è un’animazione che ci porta
all’interno di questo viaggio,
che è durato dieci anni.
Voi guardate la Terra.
Ogni volta che la Terra
fa un giro intorno al Sole
è passato un anno, evidentemente.
La traiettoria bianca
è la traiettoria di Rosetta,
all’interno del nostro sistema solare.
Questo viaggio è durato dieci anni,
e, come detto, ha percorso miliardi di km.
Non saremmo mai riusciti
ad arrivare fino alla cometa
se non avessimo usato un “trucco”
per cercare di aumentare
l’energia di Rosetta.
Questo “trucco” consiste
nel passare vicino a dei pianeti
e sfruttare la loro
attrazione gravitazionale,
quindi rubare loro un po’ di energia
per essere scaraventati
in orbite sempre più grandi.
L’abbiamo fatto tre volte con la Terra,
e l’abbiamo fatto una volta con Marte.
Potete guardare dalla grafica
come ogni volta l’orbita di Rosetta
diventa sempre più grande.
Se avessimo dovuto fare queste operazioni
soltanto col propellente
non ci saremmo mai riusciti.
Sarebbero state necessarie
decine di tonnellate di propellente,
che evidentemente non è possibile.
Guardate dopo l’ultimo passaggio
intorno alla Terra.
Questo ha schizzato Rosetta
in un’orbita grandissima,
che va a congiungersi
con quella che poi sarà quella finale,
quella della cometa.
Adesso Rosetta è talmente
lontana dal Sole,
che anche con i suoi
enormi pannelli solari
non ha più la capacità
di avere abbastanza energia
per mandare avanti tutti i suoi strumenti.
Quindi inizia la cosiddetta
fase di “ibernazione”.
Voi pensate, in questo momento
tutto viene spento.
Tutti gli strumenti,
i sistemi di comunicazione,
rimane in piedi soltanto un sistema
che permette al propellente
di non congelarsi,
e una sveglia.
Una sveglia che è pronta
per suonare due anni e mezzo dopo.
Quindi, ci troviamo,
adesso abbiamo fatto un salto temporale,
siamo nella sala di controllo dell’ESOC.
Questo è il posto
da cui si controlla Rosetta.
Sono passati due anni e mezzo
e noi non sapevamo nulla di Rosetta.
Abbiamo preso delle antenne grandissime,
una di 70 metri in America
e un’altra di 35 metri in Australia,
quindi una della NASA e una dell’ESA,
e le abbiamo puntate nello spazio,
nella posizione in cui noi credevamo
che Rosetta sarebbe stata,
dopo tutto questo tempo.
Voi immaginate, abbiamo dovuto predire
l’orbita di Rosetta per due anni e mezzo.
Questi sono i segnali
che vengono dalle due antenne diverse.
Quello che stiamo aspettando
è un picco in questo oscilloscopio,
che mostri appunto un segnale
ricevuto da una, e probabilmente
da tutte e due le stazioni.
Il problema è che
il segnale non è arrivato,
al punto in cui noi ce lo aspettavamo.
E non è arrivato dopo un quarto d’ora.
E dopo mezz’ora non c’era
ancora nessun segnale.
E li, veramente,
quasi tutti abbiamo cominciato
ad avere una sensazione molto brutta.
Voi immaginate, anni e anni
di lavoro, anni di volo,
se adesso Rosetta
non si risveglia è finito tutto,
non abbiamo più un lavoro,
non abbiamo più uno scopo,
abbiamo speso anni di energie.
E stavamo pensando già
a cosa dire alla stampa.
C’era la stampa di tutto il mondo.
Stavamo pensando a cosa fare
delle nostre vite.
E quando ormai veramente sembrava
che fosse tutto perso,
il segnale è arrivato.
Vedete che comincia questo picco
all’interno dei due oscilloscopi,
e quando c’è stata la certezza
voi potete guardare
l’esplosione di sollievo.
È come passare dall’inferno al paradiso,
è una...
(Esultano)
Ecco, è successo
pure questa volta, confesso,
m’è venuta la pelle d’oca.
Io questo video l’ho visto
100 volte, 200 volte,
[ma] ogni volta che lo vedo
mi vengono i brividi,
perché questa è l’espressione
del sentimento di un gruppo
che ha vissuto insieme
per cosi tanto tempo.
Non servono soltanto dei matematici,
dei fisici, degli ingegneri,
per fare queste cose.
Servono delle persone
che lavorano insieme.
Per me, il fattore umano in un gruppo
è una componente fondamentale.
Ed è quello che ha portato
queste persone, durante gli anni,
a capirsi, a passare
i momenti di difficoltà,
a passare sopra le difficoltà personali,
anche le ambizioni personali,
con l’idea di portare
avanti questo progetto.
Una cosa complicatissima,
che soltanto scomponendola in blocchi,
e ognuno avendo una responsabilità
e parlando insieme agli altri,
è riuscito ad arrivare a questo risultato.
Io sono veramente onorato
di aver fatto parte di questo gruppo
nella prima parte della missione.
Non dimentichiamoci che questa
non è la fine della missione.
Questo è l’inizio.
Quello che abbiamo adesso infatti
è che Rosetta comincia a fare
una grandissima frenata
e arriva a vedere la cometa.
E quello che vediamo
è una cosa che più o meno
è quello che ci aspettiamo.
La cometa per noi
è sempre stata rappresentata
come un oggetto
più o meno sferico, bitorzoluto,
e invece quello che abbiamo trovato
è una cosa completamente diversa.
Le prime immagini ci hanno dato uno shock.
Questa è una struttura
del tutto inaspettata.
Ci aspettavamo una patata
e ci ritroviamo una scamorza spaziale
che è li e che gira (Risate)
e questo ha provocato
delle reazioni incredibili.
Gli scienziati erano alle stelle:
“Questo è fantastico,
mai avremmo trovato una cosa cosi bella”.
Gli ingegneri della dinamica del volo
erano con le mani nei capelli:
“Noi dobbiamo entrare in orbita,
intorno a questo oggetto,
e ci dobbiamo fare atterrare
sopra un lander.
È una cosa di una
complessità incredibile!”.
Quindi, ci sono state discussioni,
ci sono state moltissime scelte da fare,
ma la cosa più importante era riuscire
ad arrivare vicino a questa cometa.
Immaginate che la cometa
ha un’attrazione gravitazionale
100.000 volte più piccola
di quella della Terra.
Quindi non si può parlare
di una vera e propria orbita
intorno alla cometa,
fino a quando non siamo abbastanza vicini.
E non conosciamo
come è fatta questa cometa.
Non conosciamo la sua massa,
la sua distribuzione.
Quindi gli ingegneri
della dinamica del volo di Darmstadt
hanno inventato
queste traiettorie piramidali.
Sono dei lati di 100 Km,
più o meno, di lunghezza,
scendendo sempre più verso la cometa.
Osservare la traiettoria di Rosetta,
la sua modificazione da parte
della seppur piccola gravità della cometa,
ha aiutato a capire
quale fosse la sua struttura,
quale fosse la sua massa,
e quindi a cercare di raffinare
sempre di più i cambi di traiettoria
per poter scendere sempre più vicino.
Quindi è stata una fase importantissima
in cui si studiava la cometa
e si cercava di capire
come avvicinarsi sempre di più.
Arrivati a distanze più piccole,
quindi intorno ai 30 km circa,
voi immaginate che siamo a centinaia
di milioni di km dalla Terra,
la cometa è circa tre km,
e stiamo entrando in orbite circolari,
più o meno di 30 km di raggio.
A questo punto, diventa possibile
avere delle orbite kepleriane,
come quelle dei satelliti
intorno alla Terra.
Quindi, se noi non la tocchiamo rimane li
e più o meno, certo,
con approssimazioni molto grandi,
fa delle orbite circolari.
Siamo scesi fino a dieci km,
per cercare di mappare benissimo,
e prendere foto di tutta quanta la cometa,
per decidere dove far scendere
il nostro amico Philae.
Molto importante questa fase,
come dicevo prima,
perché c’erano dei desideri contrastanti.
Gli scienziati volevano andare
in certi punti particolari,
tipicamente i più difficili
da raggiungere,
e tipicamente quelli
in cui l’illuminazione
e il contatto radio con Rosetta
sarebbero stati più complicati.
Immaginate che il lander
non parla con la Terra,
ma deve mandare i segnali a Rosetta,
che è li intorno e gira,
e Rosetta poi li manda sulla Terra.
Comunque, siamo arrivati
al momento più bello, secondo me.
Una cosa fantastica.
Nel Novembre del 2016
inizia la fase di atterraggio.
Rosetta si mette in direzione
di collisione con la cometa
e lascia il lander.
Questa è una foto fatta
dal lander, da Philae, verso l’alto.
Quindi vedete Rosetta,
la spacecraft madre, che sta li sopra,
e questa è una foto
dei suoi grandi pannelli solari.
E la foto successiva è ancora più bella,
perché è una foto fatta
da Rosetta al lander,
che ha tirato fuori
le sue tre gambe di atterraggio
e sta scendendo verso la cometa.
Foto successive ci fanno vedere
appunto il lander,
che ha iniziato ad andare verso la cometa.
E questa è l’ultima foto,
non so se vedete il puntino bianco,
del lander che si sta avvicinando.
Ci sono volute sette ore
per coprire i 22 km di distanza
dal punto del rilascio
fino al contatto a terra,
quindi immaginate una velocità
di circa 50 cm/s,
come una persona che cammina.
Ma qui passiamo alle foto
direttamente dal lander.
Questa, vedete,
è una delle tre gambe di Philae,
e questa è una distanza molto ravvicinata.
E vedete la testa della cometa.
E qui ci siamo quasi.
Questa è a 40 metri dalla superficie.
Notate questa pietra,
che si vede in alto a destra,
perché ci servirà dopo,
per capire dove è atterrato Philae.
E adesso, preparatevi alla storia:
questa è la prima immagine
della superficie di una cometa,
direttamente da un oggetto depositato li.
Non era mai successo
nella storia dello spazio,
e questa è un’immagine
che rimarrà per sempre
in tutti i libri di storia dello spazio.
È una cosa di cui
siamo tutti veramente orgogliosi.
È stata una delle più grandi
conquiste del nostro lavoro.
Questa, invece, secondo me è l’apoteosi
della matematica, dell’uomo, dell’ingegno.
Il punto in cui il lander doveva atterrare
era distante dal punto
in cui è effettivamente atterrato
di meno di 120 metri.
Stiamo parlando di una distanza
di 500.000.000 di km dalla Terra,
su una cometa di tre km,
che gira su se stessa
con un periodo di 12 ore.
Questa è una cosa che mi lascia
sempre a bocca aperta,
e il mio rispetto per colleghi e amici
della dinamica del volo
è una cosa, veramente,
che mi porto sempre dentro.
(Applausi)
Cosa è successo?
Philae ha toccato terra esattamente
nel punto in cui noi volevamo,
ma non c’è rimasto!
Nel cerchietto blu vedete
le orme delle “zampe” di Philae,
che purtroppo è rimbalzato
e se n’è volato via.
Guardate nel cerchietto rosso
a destra, quello è Philae.
L’ultima immagine di Philae
mentre sta volando via.
I sistemi per ancorarlo a terra
non hanno funzionato.
Siamo stati sfortunati?
No! Siamo stati fortunatissimi,
perché Philae è rimbalzato
un’altra volta sulla cometa
e si è fermato in un punto
che è all’interno
di quella ellisse rossa che vedete.
Ma è stata una fortuna grandissima,
perché con quella piccolissima gravità
Philae avrebbe potuto rimbalzare
e tornarsene nello spazio,
e la sua missione sarebbe finita li.
Rosetta ha cercato comunque, nel tempo,
sempre di andare a vedere, di trovarlo.
Volevamo avere una prova
del punto in cui fosse atterrato,
e finalmente, a poche settimane
prima della fine della missione,
siamo riusciti anche a trovarlo.
Vedete, nella parte in basso a destra,
c’è un ingrandimento
e si vede Philae,
incastrato in quel crepaccio,
dal quale ha fatto
tutta la sua missione di scienza.
Rosetta ovviamente
ha continuato la sua missione
durante due anni intorno alla cometa,
e ha raccolto una quantità
di scienza spettacolare.
Delle foto incredibili.
E alla fine della missione,
è stato deciso di farla atterrare,
anche lei sulla cometa.
E quindi queste che vedete
sono le ultime immagini di Rosetta,
che scende piano piano verso la cometa.
Abbiamo continuato a raccogliere scienza
fino all’ultimo momento.
E quindi vedete alla fine
si avvicina in questa parte di ombra,
fino a quando siamo arrivati al contatto.
Tutti gli strumenti sono stati spenti,
Rosetta non manderà mai più segnali.
È un momento in cui
si dovrebbe urlare di gioia,
ma vi confesso che la gran parte
delle persone al centro di controllo
aveva come una sorta
di groppo alla gola.
Dopo tutti questi anni,
vedere il segnale
che scende e diventa piatto
è una cosa veramente forte.
Ma questo mi porta però a introdurvi
l’altro punto fondamentale
del mio discorso,
e volevo farvi notare
che nessuna di queste nazioni è riuscita
a mandare Rosetta sulla cometa,
né la Francia, né l’Italia, né la Spagna.
È stato l’insieme di queste nazioni
che ha creato un sistema
capace di fare questa cosa incredibile.
L’ESA, l’Agenzia Spaziale Europea,
mette insieme 22 stati membri,
e attraverso tutti i contributi,
attraverso le migliori
personalità dello spazio,
dell’ingegneria, della scienza,
è riuscita a fare questa cosa incredibile.
Voi pensate che poche decine di anni fa,
al centro della nostra Europa,
tra francesi, tedeschi,
italiani, inglesi,
ci ammazzavamo a decine di milioni.
Io penso che il cambio sia bellissimo.
Adesso le stesse nazioni stanno li,
e insieme fanno
dei progetti spaziali incredibili.
E le due componenti del fattore umano
e della cooperazione internazionale,
secondo me,
è quello che dovete portarvi via
da questa presentazione.
E per farvelo rimanere
ancora meglio in testa
ho un esempio molto personale,
che riassume le due cose.
Questo è il giardino di casa nostra.
Mia moglie è spagnola, io sono italiano
e i nostri bimbi sono nati in Germania,
quindi hanno tre nazionalità
e parlano correntemente come madre lingua
l’italiano, lo spagnolo e il tedesco.
E quando la gente gli chiede:
“Ma voi, come vi sentite?
Vi sentite più italiani, più spagnoli…”
E loro alzano le spalle e dicono: “Boh?”.
Parlano indifferentemente le tre lingue.
Io stesso, dopo 20 anni in Germania,
non posso dire di sentirmi
al 100% italiano.
E però non mi sentirò mai
al 100% tedesco,
quindi per me c’è questa opportunità
bellissima di dire “io sono europeo!”.
Questa per me è una cosa bellissima.
E io auguro ai miei figli,
e ai vostri figli,
di avere la possibilità di vivere,
di crescere, di lavorare, di imparare
in una Europa in cui le diverse nazioni
capiscano e continuino ad approfittare
delle loro diversità,
per creare insieme qualcosa
di eccezionale ed incredibile
come è stata Rosetta.
Perché credo
che ne abbiamo veramente bisogno,
di questo tipo di cooperazione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)